well that's a really good question III
think that people get more insecure
about what they think of as high-class
living and you know we're a country of
nuvo reach people even if you came over
on the Mayflower made a ton of money
early on you've only had it for a few
hundred years so it's not we're not a
country of people who has a confidence
in class position you know we probably
most of us just made it to wherever we
are we just made it there and we don't
know and I was talking to a yacht sales
when the other damn cooking this lunch
on a yacht and it definitely not my
yacht and the yacht salesman was telling
me that whereas 20 years ago everybody
buying else was 50 years old today
everybody's 35 years old you have all of
these kind of you know like it internet
billionaire all different kinds of
billionaires made through the new
economy and he said that people will
turn to him and say is this the right
yacht is this the and thereby we're
talking about 30 million dollar yacht so
this is somebody spending 30 million
dollars which means they can you know
buy anything they want in the world and
they're asking the yacht salesman is
this the right yacht is this gonna is
this for the class i'm in today that i
wasn't in two years ago am i going to
fit in and I think that it's nice it's a
nice quality of America that people can
move so quickly but a part of that is
that they get to a place where they need
a road map and you know a big part of
what I do is giving people permission
inside whatever place they are to say
you don't need the road map of that
place there may not even be a road map
of that place you have to you have to
say I'm confident putting out this thing
and it's cool and it's fun and it's easy
and it's me and what's funny is when you
go to somebody's house who's really some
kind i remember when i was maybe 13 i
went to this you know bavarian princess
is a kind of Castle she was really into
contemporary art you lunch there and it
was the most thrown together bohemian
lunch you've ever seen and so when you
really get into you know the realm of
people who had some kind of class
whatever that even is for a thousand
years they are sometimes the most
easygoing you know about guard bohemian
Souls there are